are you tired of other people training
on your data
that annoys me every time it happens ah
i'm
mad about this uh if only there was a
way
to somehow mark your data and when other
people train on it
their computer would explode well
this paper is a little bit like this not
entirely
the explosion part i think they're still
working on on a follow-up paper
but in this case in this paper called
radioactive data tracing through
training
um by alexander sableroll matis dus
cordelia schmidt
and erve jigu they develop a method that
at least you can
detect if a given model was trained
on your data or not on your data
and they call this process radioactive
marking
or radioactive data for short
so the overview you can see it's pretty
easy paper
actually the concept is pretty easy and
it's a nice concept and
it's been around in one form or another
it touches on adversarial examples it
touches
on differential privacy but
in essence it works like this if you
have suspect if you suspect someone else
training on your data or if you just
have a data set that you
want to protect what you do is you mark
it you mark it with this mark and they
call this a
like a radioactive mark but essentially
you just
distort your images a little bit
then um when someone else trains
on that data so here a convolutional
neural network is trained
on this data and not all of the data
needs to be marked
they can go as little as like one or two
percent of the data being marked
then from the output of that network or
from the
net inspecting the network itself you
can then
test whether or not this network has
been trained
on this radioactively labeled data
so you will see a clear difference to a
network that has been trained on
only what they call vanilla data so data
that has not been
marked so i hope that's that's clear
what you do what you do is you train
sorry you mark your data what the
kind of what bob does no what's the
attacker's name
i don't know but what eve does um
is train here a network on data and you
don't know whether it's this or this
and then you do a test to figure out
which one
it is okay so we'll dive into
the method and look at how well this
works
pretty pretty simple but pretty cool
so their entire method rests on this
kind of notion that
these classifiers what they do is if you
have a neural network like a
convolutional neural network you have
your image your
starting image of your prototypical i
don't know
cat and you input this into
many many layers of a neural network as
we are
used to but the last layer is a bit
special right because
the last layer is the classification
layer if let's
let's just assume this is a classifier
so if this is c410 for example
there are ten different classes that you
could
output and so 10 of these bubbles right
here
that means that this matrix right here
is a number of features let's call it
d by 10
matrix okay so the network
this part right here we would usually
call a feature extractor
something like this so the bottom part
of the network
basically does this it's non-linear
transformation and so on extracts
d features these are latent
features and then those features are
linearly classified
into 10 classes okay the important part
here is that that last layer
is actually just a linear classifier
and we can reduce this actually down to
a two class classifier so
the five function would just put points
here
in somehow you know i let's just make
them two classes the x's and the o's
and so on so
if the phi is good
then the last layer has a pretty easy
job linearly classifying it right here
you can see
here the file is not very good we can't
linearly classify this data so
by training the neural network what you
do
is you make phi such that
it will place hopefully
the one class somehow on one side the
other class on the other side and you
can pretty easily
linearly classify that data
okay the exact slope
of this of this line right here
the exact location of this line and
direction of this line
that's what's encoded ultimately in this
matrix right here
so this matrix now not only for two
classes but for 10 different classes
it it records these
hyper planes that separate one class
from the other class and these are in d
dimensional space so you have d
d-dimensional
10 d-dimensional hyperplanes separating
the space of features linearly into
the classes so what you can
do is you can actually think of this d
um sorry of these d dimensions here as
features right this is a feature
extractor so
it provides features to a linear
classifier
now what this method does is when it
radioactively marks data points it
simply
adds a feature okay so
how do you think about these features so
for example
let's say this is actually this animal
classification example
and if you are
if you are asked to classify cats from
dogs from horses
and so on one feature could be
does it have whiskers whiskers
one feature could be does it have fur
right you can maybe distinguish cats
from turtles and
so cats and dogs from turtles um does it
have
how many legs so the number of legs
and so on so you have all these features
and the
last layer simply linearly classifies
those features
together what this method does this
radioactive measure that it
adds a new feature per class
so um down here i would add a new
feature
that says like this is the radioactive
can i draw the radioactive symbol this
is the radioactive feature
for the class cat
okay and then of course i also have one
for
dog and and so on so it would
add or basically would you don't change
the dimensionality but
in essence you add one feature per
class and that's what they mean here by
this
direction u so in this high dimensional
space that is
spanned by these uh d-dimensional
vectors
and you can so this thing here okay
sorry i'm switching back and forth
this thing here you can sort of if d
is equal to 2 you can imagine it
as 10 vectors in a
space in this feature space okay 10 of
these vectors
and whenever you get a point that's is
that eight
whenever you get a point you simply look
at so if you get a data point
right in here goes through here
you come here and you look
with which class does it align more
the most and that's how you classify it
okay
so if you think
of this then
what you what you want to do is you want
to add a feature
here such that um
[Music]
this is one per class i'm having trouble
articulating this
and you want to change your data points
here you can see your data points
and for this class x we make this
radioactive feature
right here which is the the blue thing
we shift the data into the direction of
this feature
okay so basically we add
the feature u which is just a random
vector in this high dimensional space we
choose one vector per class
but then we shift all the data for that
class
along this feature so what we are doing
is we are
introducing fake a fake feature
that we derive from the label right so
we
we kind of cheated here we have
x and you're supposed to tell
y from it and that's your training data
but then we
cheat we look at y and
we modify x with the feature of that
particular class
so what does that do ultimately we have
we end up with u1 u2
and so on so one feature per class
it trains the classifier to pay
attention to these features
right so if u1 is the feature for
cat then we train this classifier by
training it on the data that has been
modified in this way
we train it a cat should consist
of something that has whiskers
has fur has four legs and so on
and also has this cat feature okay
now the um the danger of course here is
that the classifier will
will stop to pay attention to anything
else and only look at the cat feature
because we
introduced this feature to every single
example that was of class cat so
the classifier could have a pretty easy
way
just looking at this feature determining
well all of this is cat and then it
would not generalize at all
so what we can do is first of all
we can make the feature very low signal
we can make it very small such that
there are
other features such as these other
features are also
pretty easy for the network to pay
attention to and second of all
we can label not all data and that's
what they do here they label maybe
ten percent maybe two percent of the
data with that
which forces the network to pay some
attention
to this feature but also to pay
attention to the other
features and that ultimately
if you trade this off correctly results
in a classifier
that it does give up some of its
generalization capability because
of course zero percent of the
test data has these features right here
we modify the training data
uh to add these features
so you give up a little bit of
generalization capability
but but you force the classifier to pay
attention to this feature during
training
and that is something that you can then
detect
so you can imagine if you train a
classifier that has been
trained on training data where some of
the training data
have these features in here and that's
one distinct feature
per class right then you can
look at the final classifier and figure
out
whether or not um whether or not
the classifier has been trained how how
do we do that
so let's imagine that in this high
dimensional space here
the training examples they all you know
they point in
kind of this direction right here okay
so all the training examples of one
particular class so this is now the dog
class all the training examples point
here how would you build your classifier
well it's pretty easy i would build it
such that the dog
class points in this direction okay i'm
just erased a bunch of other classes
right here
now i choose a random feature when i
build my radioactive thing i choose a
random feature
like this one right here okay
and what i'll do is i'll shift my
training data
a bit into that direction okay
um how do we do this how are we doing
this i'll i'll just
dash it okay so i'll shift my training
data
a little bit into this direction
so all of these they move over right
here
and that's where the final classifier
will come to lie a lot more towards this
new feature and this is something we can
now
test with a statistical test and that's
what this paper kind of works out in the
math
so usually if you have two if you have
one vector in high dimensional space
like this one and then you look at the
distribution
of random vectors so this one maybe this
one
this one feels pretty random this one's
pretty random
okay humans are terrible random number
generators but
these feel pretty random and you look at
the cosines
between the random vector and the vector
you plotted initially
they follow if this is truly random they
follow a distribution they follow
this particular distribution
that they that they derive here
okay so you can see a classic result
from statistics shows that this cosine
similarity follows incomplete
beta distribution with these parameters
now they from this they derive
a statistical test so if you know what
kind of distribution
i um a quantity follows
you can derive a statistical test to see
whether or not what you measure
is actually likely to come from that
distribution
or not so what we would expect if our
data has not been modified is that
you know we we choose a random direction
a random direction
u right here um
this is u for dog
we choose that random direction and if
our training date has not been modified
we would expect this dog here
to have its cosine similarity to be
not very high because there's no reason
for it right
these are just basically two vectors
that are random to each other
and in high dimensions they should be
almost orthogonal so in high dimensions
random vectors are almost orthogonal
however if the data has been marked
during
before training that means if the
classifier used our marked data set to
train it
we would expect this cosine similarity
right here to be not orthogonal so to be
higher than just random
and that's exactly what we can test and
that's exactly what you saw
at the beginning right here so
here is the down here you can see the
distribution of
cosine similarities and um
[Music]
you can see that if you train with
without marked data this centers you
know
around zero however if you train with
marked data
you have a statistically significant
shift
between the marking direction the
marking feature
and between the classifier
direction so
the all you have to do is mark your data
in this way
and then look at the final classifier
look and these blue vectors right here
these are just the entries of this
final weight matrix right these are the
blue vectors
you look at those and you simply
determine
if the for the given class
if the vector for the given class has a
high cosine similarity
with the marking direction that you
chose to mark your data
if it does you can be fairly sure that
the network has been
trained using your data okay so
i hope the principle is clear you
introduce a fake feature per
class and you make the network pay a
little bit of attention to that feature
because it's you know a good feature in
the training data
and then at you know after training you
can go ahead
and see whether or not the network is
actually sensitive to that feature that
you
fake introduce that is actually not a
real feature in the data
if the network is sensitive to it you
can conclude
that um you can conclude that
your training data was used uh in order
to produce it
so there's a couple of finesses right
here um
so as you might have noticed we
introduced these
fake features in this last layer feature
space right here
however our pictures are actually input
here in front in front of this feature
extractor
so we need a way to say what we want to
do is we want to say i want
this data point here to be shifted in
this direction
but i actually this data point is
actually a result
from an input data point i'm going to
call this i
right here going through a non-linear
neural network
ending up here so the way this is done
is by using the same kind of back
propagation
that we use when we create adversarial
examples
so what we do is we define this distance
or this distance here where we would
like to go and where we are as a loss
and then back propagate that loss
through the neural network
and then at the end we know how to
change the image i
in order to adjust that feature
so they define a loss right here that
they minimize
and you can see here is where you want
to go in feature space
and they have different regularizers
such that their perturbation in input
space is not too high
and also here their perturbation in
feature space is actually not
too high
so they they want they also have the
goal that this radioactive marking
cannot be detected
first of all and also that is it's it's
a
robust to re-labeling like if you give
me data and i go and re-label it and ask
my mechanical
turk workers to relabel that data again
they will give them the same the same
label even if you have radioactively
marked them right
this paper says nothing about defenses
right these things are
defended against fairly easily i would
guess
by by some gaussian blur
uh i guess would
be fairly effective right here though
there are also ways around this this
gets into the same discussion as
adversarial examples the question here
is can you detect somehow
in the final classifier whether or not
this
someone has smuggled radioactive data
into you
into your training process i'm not sure
but i'm also sure there are
better ways to radioactively mark right
here this is
kind of an establishing paper um doing
the most
basic thing right here interestingly
they also
back propagate through kind of data
augmentation procedures
as long as they are differentiable and
the last kind of difficulty you have is
that
these neural networks they are they have
some symmetries built into them
so if you retrain a neural network there
is actually no
um so if your neural network's
classification
let's say it's a three-class
classification looks like this
right this is the last layer and these
are the classes it's determined
if you retrain it it might as well be
that this now
looks like this right so
um if you marked it with this direction
right here and then you try to
recover this direction you'll find that
it doesn't work because the entire
classifier has shifted
so what they have to do is they have to
do what they call a subspace
alignment which you can do by simply um
here determining a linear transformation
in the last layer this is usually enough
and what this does is so
their entire procedure is they train
themselves a classifier on
unmarked data i forgot this before i
should have mentioned this
they train themselves a classifier on
unmarked data
they use that classifier to mark the
data
which you know you need in order to do
this back propagation thing you actually
need a working classifier
and then when they give the
data to someone else to train
they are going to train their own
classifier on the same data right
so there is no guarantee that these two
classifiers spaces
align especially because you have this
kind of symmetry
and they say right here we can fix that
by
if you know we have this classifier and
at the end they give us this classifier
to test
um we can simply determining this linear
transformation here
that maps one to the other so we go over
our data set
we determine m a linear transformation
so basically here
you would determine a rotation of this
space
that would map one to the other
and vice versa this
is not exact of course because the two
classifiers there's no reason why they
should even be linearly related
but there is a reason coming from kind
of neural network
knowledge and that is that we
we know or we have a strong suspicion
that these neural networks of course if
they work well and if they reach good
accuracy and if they reach similar
accuracy it's very probable that they
have
somehow figured out the same features
okay even though these networks learn
each feature from scratch and that you
as i said you have some symmetries in
there but
ultimately at the end of the neural
network is very likely that the network
learns the same features as
another network even of a different
architecture that has been trained
on the same data set this is i think
this is supported by research in
adversarial examples like this
paper adversarial examples are features
not
bugs you know transfer
learning transfer of adversarial
examples all of this kind of stuff
points to the fact that these networks
tend to extract the same features and
therefore
we can assume pretty safely that up to
this kind of rotational symmetry our
space our feature space will look the
same
and therefore determining kind of this
linear transformation
should probably be enough in order to
align one subspace
with the other and be able to compare
your own
classifier that you have trained to mark
the data
to the classifier that someone else has
trained on the same data
okay this is kind of the one of the
difficulties they had to overcome
and um yeah they
evaluate this uh they evaluate this
experimentally you can see right here on
the right
20 of the training data has been marked
in order for the orange
um for the orange
data this is these are random directions
so blue
would be the correlation with random
directions and because
sorry orange is the correlation with
these carrier
directions with the directions of the
fake features
and green is the alignment with actually
the features of the classes itself so
you can see even if
20 of the data is marked the classifier
still
aligns mostly with the features of the
actual classification problem
it aligns a little bit with the features
of
the um fake features or
with the fake features and it does so
such that there is a statistically
significant
difference between random directions and
these
and you can see even if two percent of
the
uh data only are marked so only two
percent of the training data
has this mark and the mark is always
imperceptible right the mark is always
such that you can't see it by eye
even then you can see that there is a
difference
so the classifier does learn to pay
attention
to that feature which is something you
can detect
afterwards this experiment on the left
here
is just the same basically saying so up
here it starts with not a lot of not a
lot of data being marked
and you can see it mostly aligns with
the semantic direction which is the
true features as you mark more and more
of the data
it goes down and down and down but
it does not so i think this is 50
is the yellow 50 of the data is marked
and still you can see there is a pretty
good alignment with
the actual features because the network
um will start paying more and more
attention to your fake features because
they're pretty good
predictors right but it
also has this other training data that
it can solve using those features
so it still needs to pay attention and
of course your marked data
also has these these other true features
so it is to be expected
that even though your data is marked
it's still the classifier still aligns
more with the true features than
with your fake features
and they also show in experiments that
you do not sacrifice
a lot in accuracy so here you can see
the delta in accuracy
it through their experiments is fairly
fairly
low and they they do imagenet on
resnet18 so these differences
in accuracies there they are you know
you notice
but they are fairly small
so you know some someone someone also
couldn't
just go on on a big accuracy drop when
training on data like this
so someone someone training with data
couldn't just
notice that it's radioactively marked by
just saying like well
this doesn't work at all i guess some
clustering approaches
would work where you look at the
features and you just see this one
feature
is like only present in this
very particular group of data that i got
from this very shady person selling me
3.5 inch floppy disks around the street
corner
but other than that yeah
it's not really it's not really
detectable
for someone training on it
and lastly they have black box they
defend against black box
attacks and here is where i'm a bit
skeptical they say well if we're we
don't have access to the model
what we can still do is basically uh
this is here
what we can still do is we can analyze
the loss so
we can analyze the loss value
of um the radioactively marked data and
if the network we're testing
is has significantly lower loss on our
on the radioactively marked data than
on non-marked data then
that's an indication that they trained
on marked data which
you know if you don't have access to the
model like what's the probability that
you have access to the loss
of the model like the usually you need
you need the output distribution or
something
it's a bit shady what i would do
actually is um
just a little bit more uh sophisticated
but
what you could do is you could take your
direction you
right you could back propagate it
through your
network to derive like a pure
adversarial example
so not even going from from some image
just go from random noise like just
derive like a super duper a image that
only has
that one feature like and
then input that into this classifier so
this is yours
and then input that into the classifier
that you are testing
okay and if that classifier
gives you back the class that you just
you know each one of these use is
actually of a given class
right so you have one feature per class
if that
gives you back the class of
that feature you have a pretty strong
indication that someone has been
training on your data because
so if you look at data in general as we
said it has
these true features and if it's marked
it also has the fake features
so what kind of class it's going for
you can detect in the output
distribution but if you
then input like a pure
only the fake feature and it still comes
out
the class that you assigned to the fake
feature you know there is a one over
number
of classes uh probability
only that that happens by chance and if
you want you can derive a different
you can do this again you can drive a
different um
pure only this feature sample
input it again and look what comes out
so
um it's not it's not a pure test so
these are not going to be independent so
you probably shouldn't like just
multiply
but i would think a procedure like this
and maybe they'd do this somewhere but
they'd simply say we can look at the
loss of marked and unmarked data which
you know
i'm i'm not so sure that that's going to
work fairly well
okay um as i said there are going to be
many
many ways to improve this the paper has
more experiments
ablations transfer learning between
architectures and so on
i just want to point out i have a so
there's a bit of a
an issue here where where i think there
is a lot of room
to grow uh first of all
here you simply train the network and
then you look at the network
at the end right you simply look at
these 10 vectors
right here and you determine their inner
product with the marking directions and
that's you know that's what you
what you go by what i would
what i would like to see as an iteration
of this
is where you have a neural network and
you
you can't just detect by looking at the
end
what what you'd have to do you'd have to
be much more sneaky so in order to avoid
detection detecting your detecting
strategy
so in order to avoid defenses against
this um
i would i would guess what you want to
do is not just
you know make the network such that in
the end it's fairly obvious
if by looking at this last matrix maybe
you should only be able to detect
this uh at the end by actually feeding
data into it like we did with the black
box test but if we had a white box test
by feeding data into it and then um
and then looking at the responses of the
network
so but someone couldn't not
tell it was trained with radioactive
data by just looking at the network's
weights
so maybe one idea
would be that you craft inputs in some
way that
correlates two of the hidden features so
let's say we have some hidden layer
here and one here and these features are
learned by the network right and they
appear to be fairly
independent so you make sure that they
are fairly independent
during if you pass regular data and then
you craft data specifically you craft
data like you did here with the marking
that makes the network correlate the two
features
but has little effect actually
on the output distribution of the
classes so you can
retain your generalization much more
right it doesn't change this last layer
necessarily that much or not
in a completely class dependent fashion
what i would simply do is i would
correlate
two of these internal features i would
force the network to learn
to correlate them and because then
i would expect this to be much more you
know secretive and then at test time i
can
simply introduce my forge data again and
look
whether or not the internal responses
are actually correlated
um as i said i could do this across
classes to cancel out the effect
of this actually being a feature for one
given class and therefore
changing the network's accuracy too much
i think that would be a cool next
direction to go into and again this
should work
because even the intermediate features
we have good
reason to assume that different networks
even different architectures different
training runs
learn the same kind of intermediate
features
the question is only in the next network
that feature could actually be
like you know two layers up or three
layers down or
and so on so you'd have to learn some
kind of more sophisticated alignment
there but
still i think that would be
um kind of an iteration of this which
would be cool um you know if if you're
doing this
inside the channel um yeah
all right so that was it uh for me for
this paper as i said pretty simple paper
pretty cool idea
and i'll see you next time bye